I HAVE FINISHED MY BEDROOM.
I HAVE FINISHED THE OFFICE.
AND I'M JUST WRAPPING UP
THE LIVING ROOM.
- OKAY.
- SO YEAH.
- I'LL GET PACK-A-LACKIN'.
- I LOVE IT. I LOVE IT.
- MIND IF I PUT ON
SOME MUSIC?
- I DO NOT. I DO NOT.
- ALL RIGHT.
I GOT THIS NEW DUBSTEP.
- UH, DUBSTE--WHAT IS THAT?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
- OH, DUDE,
YOU'RE GONNA LOVE IT.
- OH, COOL.
COOL, MAN.
[stereo beeps]
[peaceful electronic intro]
OOH, I LIKE THIS.
- WAIT FOR THE DROP.
- I'M SORRY, "THE DROP"?
[thrumming electronic bass line]
♪
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
- WHAT?
- WHAT IS THIS?
- I CAN'T HEAR YOU!
[music stops]
- [gasping]
WHAT IS THAT?
- THE MUSIC?
- I'M SORRY, IS THAT MUSIC?
- OH, YEAH.
DUDE, THAT'S THE DUBSTEP, MAN.
THAT'S MY JAM.
- WELL, IT'S--
IT'S A LITTLE, UH,
LOUD AND DISORIENTING,
AND, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE BEING A LITTLE ROUGH
WITH MY THINGS.
- ROUGH WITH--
DUDE, YOUR STUFF IS FINE.
- WHY AM I SWEATING SO MUCH?
- BECAUSE YOU'RE FEELIN' IT.
- IS THAT A GOOD THING?
- YES!
COME ON, MAN.
JUST GIVE IT ANOTHER SHOT.
- OKAY. OKAY.
I WILL.
[thrumming bass line,
electronic chirps]
♪
- WHOA, DUDE!
YOU'RE TOTALLY JACKING
MY FLOW UP.
- DUDE, YOUR NOSE IS BLEEDING,
AND SO IS MINE.
[gasping]
- [laughing]
AWESOME.
- IT DOESN'T REALLY SEEM
LIKE MUSIC TO ME.
- OKAY. WOW.
WALLY GETTING
A LITTLE BIT OLD.
- NO, DON'T DO THAT.
- ALL RIGHT.
- COME ON.
- NO.
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT.
OKAY.
UM, YEAH, WHAT WOULD YOU
RATHER LISTEN TO?
I CAN HOOK YOU UP WITH SOME
HOOTIE & THE BLOWFISH,
IF THAT'S YOUR--
- OH, THAT'S FUNNY.
- IS THAT GOOD?
WANT SOME COLOR ME BADD?
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
D--GO AHEAD.
I DON'T CARE.
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
GO AHEAD AND PLAY IT.
I DON'T CARE.
BECAUSE I'M NOT THAT OLD.
I CAN GET INTO IT, OKAY?
WE JUST--LET'S JUST GET
THIS STUFF PACKED.
PLAY IT.
[erratic electronic beats,
mixed sound effects]
♪
[screams]
[glass shatters,
car alarm blares]
- [gasps]
- I THINK I'M GETTING IT!
- YEAH!
HA, HA!
[laughing maniacally]